liebe freunde das ist ein großer erfolg
für sachsen-anhalt man muss bedenken in
welcher weise wir bekämpft werden von
allen parteien aber auch vor der antifa
und wie der wahlkampf gerade in sachsen
anhalt versucht wurde zu beschädigen von
unseren politischen gegnern aber das
ergebnis hat er tisch darauf völlig
richtig kommentiert ich will aber noch
etwas hinzufügen die cdu in sachsen
anhalt die ja wie haseloff so tut
eigentlich konservativ ist aber doch
leider gezwungen ist mit den grünen zu
regieren ist jetzt nicht mehr gezwungen
mit den grünen zu regieren
und jetzt werden wir mal sehen welchen
weg sie ein
welchen weg sie geht wenn sie wieder
diese koalition bildet dann ist deutlich
dass die cdu keinerlei konservative
werte mir in zukunft in zukunft mehr
vertreten wird das heißt wenn eine
regierungsbildung so stattfindet wie
herr haseloff bis jetzt wie er sagt
gezwungen war zu regieren
dann können wir nur sagen sind wir die
einzige partei die gegen die deutschland
abschafft sozusagen ins feld führt und
wir wollen in dieser konstellation die
stärkste partei im bundestag werden
aber liebe freunde wir haben gelernt das
ist ein schwieriger weg denn eins ist
bei dieser wahl auch deutlich geworden
immer am ende wird der ministerpräsident
die partei des ministerpräsidenten noch
mal gewählt das ist in mecklenburg
vorpommern so gewesen bei der spd das
sind brandenburg bei der spd gewesen in
sachsen bei der cdu gewesen das ist hier
auch gewesen
das heißt in den ländern sind die
ministerpräsident starke figuren
nun will ich frau merkel nicht so
starken figur machen
aber die frau ist gottseidank weg liebe
freunde
[Applaus]